Sakina where you from Harlan origin port
look how long you been down here
97 you've been in Skid Row since 97 no I
mean in Lausanne no no I joined up on
Skid Row
my I was married to Kai that American
know too well between us too
and we and you're sleeping we're third
in Ross and the other side of y'all
women know what Women's Center they
always had in the old downtown women
that's nice place to sleep yep my own
apartment I'm all Ephrata but we sure I
have to show you we have a community
bathroom and community kitchen yeah
that's a nice warm place to sleep
oh yeah it's the street yep have you
been on the street sleep as well before
I moved in you yeah that's rough I've
been down here some some nights first
it's so cold
people just laid on the sidewalk all
night and then it rains or whatever it's
just so rough
what's the craziest thing you've seen
down here in Skid Row I've seen crazy
stuff but you're living down here so
you've seen it housing the dog tell me a
story - I've seen women
let me see yeah I'm gonna run down the
street naked God
hit me so totally crazy I saw a woman
one morning Sun was just coming up I saw
a woman taking a crap in the middle of a
big crowded sidewalk just like she just
dropped your pants oh yeah took a dump
right there on the sidewalk or in the
broad daylight that's crazy
haven't seen that before
so your nose what happened your nose
okay pay for the pipe wrench you got hit
with a pipe wrench that was here on Skid
Row
yeah it's a rough neighborhood
yeah that
that'll wreck your day right yeah did
and you never got it straightened out
her name no I'm just you just left it be
this is never placed somewhere down here
you can get that taken care I'm not I'm
not gonna get taken here like your pants
oh thanks
let me see your shoes too so do your
family you have kids yeah I've got 21
year old daughter your three grandkids
[Music]
my dad got me married after my mom
passed away and got two older sisters
one younger brother
- sister just that brothers
he doesn't happy was I crazy yeah where
they're all important no I get him
then they know you're down here yep do
you talk to them
oh yeah so you're doing drugs and all or
no you seem great
you seem clean I'm all yours you just
can't get it
you just can't get money together to get
a job or no no I'm on disability so for
what my seizures oh you have seizures
like grand mal seizures big yeah and
those are brought on just by what get
everything stress that'll slow you down
what are your dreams what would you love
to see happen in the next five years in
your life or would you like to be
married again
you talk to your daughter oh yeah doctor
a lot
she's got a family or she's working or
was she just call right now one way of
college that's good where she going to
school
upon State University okay give you a
little something to make your day easier
excellent
so are you making money here on the
street not much as I used to but there
were there'll be guys that pick you up
yeah and how often is that gone every
night every night
so what hour is that gonna depend on my
night goes I'm in culinary school right
now so I'm out call me up I come out
here once in a while you're gonna cut
let's go
and you do business with these guys you
do it in their car they take you some
hotel cars
wherever yeah of course money will you
make on I really good and I over $200
I'm really that's good
of course my dudes in jail who's that
his name is Casey's in jail they busted
him for sales you want to sell on
anything what it was they pulled up on
his homeboy yeah his homeboys a girl
well they told him how the ten-day
vacation was in and three female
snitched on him so he's easy yeah your
fool to get out in January but a riot
broke out so he won't be getting knocked
out October 2 here
where can I drop you off 750 on the
other side right okay
go around the bar
I got shot you got shot yeah
Crocker three times I get you poor words
in my back they told me move the one out
of harm and you still have you still
have bullets on your body my back they
can't pull not gonna leave me paralyzed
I'm a survivor I'd survive down here for
years I've been seeing you down here for
about five six years yeah yeah you
actually look you look a little cleaner
and better now than I saw you I think my
photograph too you didn't look so good
well good luck to you oh yeah they seem
to be doing in the right direction